al sur de India su brillo y abjey su
pareja hace 10 años a finales de 2021
celebraron una ceremonia en la que
intercambiaron sus votos en presencia de
sus seres queridos una Unión presentada
en su momento como uno de los primeros
matrimonios entre personas del mismo
sexo en el país
un día pensé Por qué esperar nuestros
amigos y familiares saben que somos
pareja nuestros amigos nuestros colegas
nuestros estudiantes todos nos han
mostrado siempre su apoyo Porque esperar
Hagamos una ceremonia llamemos a todos
nuestros familiares y demostrémosle que
estamos juntos y sobre todo felices de
estar juntos
sin embargo cuatro años después de la
despenalización de la homosexualidad el
matrimonio gay sigue sin estar permitido
en India los dos hombres han recurrido
al tribunal supremo para que se
reconozca oficialmente su Unión y así
dar más visibilidad a las parejas lgtb
[Música]
el matrimonio sigue siendo un momento
muy importante en la sociedad India si
no estás casado en todo estás excluido
así que si se produce Este cambio Si por
fin conseguimos el derecho a casarnos
legalmente automáticamente eso hará que
seamos más aceptados por esta sociedad y
también iniciará un verdadero debate
permitirá que otras personas salgan del
armario y proclamen su sexualidad alto y
claro
disfrutar de los mismos derechos que las
parejas heterosexuales esto es también
lo que reivindican parte y udé son
pareja desde hace 17 años y están
criando dos hijos concebidos mediante
gestación subrogada pero la
imposibilidad de unirse ante la ley les
impide ejercer plenamente de sus
derechos paternales oficialmente es
reconocido como padre de sus dos hijos
tenemos dos hijos juntos pero no tengo
estatuto legal legalmente no existo no
soy su padre Qué debo hacer tengo que
luchar por este derecho si mi pareja
muriera tendría automáticamente derecho
sobre mis hijos no si uno de mis hijos
tiene que ser hospitalizado mi pareja no
está presente y solo un familiar cercano
puede tomar una decisión médica de
urgencia soy yo Ese familiar cercano
tampoco
si las próximas semanas el tribunal
supremo falla a favor de las uniones
entre personas del mismo sexo India
seguiría el único presidente asiático el
de Taiwán que reconoció el matrimonio
gay en 2019